tous attendent souvent non non non non
c'est une saisine vous vous l'avez plus
sinon tu auras son désordre histoire de
glaire et apprennent des pet food
lapaska délégation
à peu près fines par jour effectivement
les jours où je à 3h30 chou un retard du
matin je prends je me lave effectivement
tout ce qui est à laver pour avoir une
intime correct et je me souviens toi
mature qui est obsédé par le l'hygiène
les médecins trouvent que dans les
sociétés modernes on se lave trop et
qu'on enlève le sébum qui assure la
cause est bonne à tous les cinq jours et
cinq fois de marc jour non il ya un lien
vous l'avez combien de fois vous après a
priori une fois par jour mais le jour
vraiment chouard tafer qui mangent de
l'âme les parties et qu'il faut laver
d'accord quelles sont les parties eh ben
les parties auxquelles on peut avoir
accès dans le métro cette garde là et on
peut avoir accès à un régime plus bas à
d'accord
non parce que d'autres mettront en accès
à vos partenaires
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]